tonight in Las Vegas the sport of boxing
could get a shot in the arm by pressing
over with another combat sport
undefeated boxer Floyd Mayweather jr.
takes on mixed martial arts champion
Conor McGregor in one of the most
anticipated fights in years both
fighters are super welterweights but as
part of Evans reports this showdown is
receiving heavyweight hype after three
million-dollar fighters it's an 800
million dollar fighters the verbal
sparring began long before the first
punch is thrown for the last two months
Floyd Mayweather and Conor McGregor had
been on a trash-talking tour Conor
McGregor and you can't disrespect black
people period promoting the unusual
matchup between a mixed martial arts
champion and a man who many consider to
be the best pound-for-pound boxer in
history after 21 years I've been hit
with everything and I'm still right here
it's the unknown factor that's part of
the interest al Bernstein is announcing
the fight for Showtime a division of CBS
Conor McGregor is a complete unknown in
a boxing ring and Mayweather is 40 years
old off a two-year layoff that one-two
punch is helping create intense
anticipation at an big-money
pay-per-view sales will likely be the
largest ever surpassing Mayweather's
2015 bout with Manny Pacquiao which
earned more than 400 million as for the
fighters Mayweather the overwhelming
favorite is eyeing a two to 300
million-dollar payday McGregor could
earn up to 100 million win or lose but
he'll have to stick to boxing rules no
kicking no grappling ticket sales had
been slower than expected at a time when
the struggling sport of boxing needs a
knockout who stands to benefit from this
from a business perspective boxing or
MMA it's interesting there's more
pressure I think on Mayweather in boxing
than there is on McGregor and mixed
martial arts because it's a boxing match
and because Mayweather is the favored a
group of 100 ringside doctors now says
McGregor is so overmatched the fight
shouldn't take place at all having
her box professionally before their
concern he could be seriously injured
tonight for CBS this morning Saturday
Carter Evans Los Angeles according to
Deadline Hollywood the promoters of this
fight could net between 700 million and
all but and a billion dollars for this
fight it's from all the pay-per-view
money you said earlier you'd take the
hundred million and get punched nobody's
offered though aisha's you know 100
million I'm it's all about the
pay-per-view dollars now I pay Anthony
if you were in the ring with someone not
anything I'm not it's not happening